OVER THE PAST 18 MONTHS HAVE
CREATED A LIST OF DISLOYAL
OFFICIALS.
FORMER CIA OFFICER AND
CONGRESSMAN RYAN EUNICE.
WHY IS ALL OF THIS HAPPENING
NOW?
AND WHY THE FREAK OUT AMONG THE
NEVER TRUMPERS AND THE LEFT?
>> I CAN TELL YOU WHEN IT WAS
SUPPOSED TO START, IT WAS
SUPPOSED TO START WHEN
GENERAL FLYNN CLAYMAN HAS AS
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR.
I KNOW FROM MY DISCUSSIONS WITH
HIM I SERVED ON THE TRANSITION
TEAM THAT HE THOUGHT THAT THE
BUREAUCRACY AND
WASHINGTON, D.C., ACROSS ALL THE
INTEL AGENCIES WAS WAY TOO BIG.
HE THOUGHT IT SHOULD BE SHRUNK
DOWN.
AND THE DNI WHERE HE IS GOING,
THAT IS A BUREAUCRACY THAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE AS STRATEGIC
PLANNING ARE.
ONE OF ITS ONLY GOALS WAS TO TRY
TO FIX THE PROCESS BY WHICH YOU
GET SECURITY CLEARANCES.
AND HERE WE ARE, NEARLY TWO
DECADES LATER, THAT’S THE ONE
THING THAT THEY HAVEN’T FIXED.
ALL THEY HAVE DONE IS GOT LARGER
AND LARGER AND LARGER.
SO REPUBLICANS ACTUALLY BELIEVE
THAT THE DNI DOES NEED TO BE
DOWNSIZED.
BUT I HAVE TO SAY, LAURA, JUST
SO I AM PERFECTLY CLEAR.
I AM NOT AWARE OF ANY BLACKLISTS
THAT HAVE BEEN CREATED AND
WASHINGTON.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE A FAKE NEWS
STORY OF SOME KIND.
THE OVERALL OBJECTIVE OF
REDUCING THE SIGNS OF THESE
AGENCIES IS A GOOD ONE.
THE MORE PEOPLE WE HAVE OUT IN
THE FIELD COME UP THE MUCH
BETTER WE ARE.
>> Laura: I LOVE THIS IDEA
THAT THE PRESIDENT SHOULD
ACTIVELY WANT TO RECRUIT PEOPLE
WHO WORK AGAINST HIS AGENDA AND
HAVE THEM POPULATE IS A
ADMINISTRATION.
THIS IS CRAZY TOWN.
THE IDEA THAT YOU WOULD HAVE
PEOPLE WHO ARE BURROWED INTO
WORK AGAINST YOUR
ADMINISTRATION’S PRIORITIES IS
LUNACY.
NO ONE WOULD COME UP WITH THAT.
BRIAN, REMEMBER THAT BIG MEDIA
BOMBSHELL IN THE RUSSIA
COLLUSION LAST WEEK?
NOW EVEN CNN IS REPORTING IT WAS
BOGUS.
SHELBY PEARSON TOLD LAWMAKERS ON
THE HOUSE UNTIL COMMODITY THAT
RUSSIA WAS INTERVIEWING WITH THE
2020 ELECTION WITH THE GOAL OF
HELPING TRUMP.
THE INTELLIGENCE DOESN’T SAY
THAT.
A MORE REASONABLE INTERPRETATION
OF THE INTEL IS NOT THAT THAT
THEY HAVE A PREFERENCE, IT’S A
STEP SHORT OF THAT.
IT’S MORE THAT THEY UNDERSTAND
THAT THE PRESIDENT TO SOMEONE
AND THEY CAN WORK WITH, THAT HE
IS A DEALMAKER.
SO BRIAN, HOW WOULD AN INTEL
BRIEFER WHO IS DESCRIBED AS
SOMEONE WHO HAS A REPUTATION OF
BEING AND DID JUDICIOUS THE IN J
HER WORDS?
>> IN THE INTELLIGENCE ACADEMY
SADDENS THEM ONTO THE HILL, NOT
SENDING THE BUS.
WE HAVE ONE OF TWO PROBLEMS HERE
WITH THIS PERSON.
WE HAVE SOMEBODY WHO IS EITHER
INCOMPETENT, WHICH ISN’T
REASSURING, OR SOMEBODY WHO HAS
A BIPARTISAN HACK.
WHICH IS ALSO DEEPLY ALARMING.
PERHAPS BOTH.
LET’S LOOK AT THOSE TWO PIECES.
IF SHE WAS A CAREER SATELLITE
IMAGERY SPECIALIST, MY THEN DID
DNI SELECT HER FOR THIS ROLE IN
THE DEPTHS OF POLITICAL
ANALYSIS?
THE NUANCE NECESSARY FOR THAT, I
DON’T KNOW.
IT’S SHOCKING.
BUT YET WE CAN’T ALSO SAY, CAN
WE, THAT SHE DIDN’T HAVE ANY
PARTICULAR BIAS.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER OF COURSE HAD A
POLITICAL BIAS.
A MULTIPLE OF THEM ACTUALLY.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT HE WAS LEAKING
TO ACHIEVE HIS PARTISAN GOALS.
WE CAN ALSO SAY THAT THERE WAS
NOTHING NEFARIOUS THERE.
TO ME, AS A FORMER OFFICER,
THAT’S ACTUALLY THE MOST
ALARMING AND SAD PART OF THE
STORY.
YES, IT’S BAD WOULD HAPPEN.
BUT IT’S THE FACT THAT YOU OR I
CAN’T HAVE FAITH IN THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE SO MANY PROBLEMS, SO
MANY ENEMIES THAT WE HAVE TO
TACKLE AND DEFINED AND
NEUTRALIZED.
AND HOW DO WE DO THAT, HOW DOES
THE PRESIDENT DO THAT?
IF THEY CAN’T HAVE FAITH OF HIS
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE IS ON HIS
SIDE AND ON THE SIDE OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
INSTEAD, DOING WHAT THEY WANT TO
DO FOR THEIR OWN PERSONAL
PARTISANSHIP.
>> Laura: APPARENTLY NEEDS TO
HIRE MORE PEOPLE LIKE SHELBY
PETERSON.
THAT’S WHAT HE SUPPOSED TO DO.
CONGRESSMAN, BREAKING TONIGHT,
THIS IS ABOUT YOU.
HOUSE REPUBLICANS CONSIDERING
CRIMINAL REFERRALS AGAINST MOLAR
PROSECUTORS.
IF YOU ARE LOOKING INTO THOSE
302, THOSE INFAMOUS 302’S.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US TONIGHT
BECAUSE PEOPLE WANT
ACCOUNTABILITY HERE.
>> SO SLOWLY BUT SURELY, SOME OF
THOSE REPORTS ARE BEING
DECLASSIFIED.
SO ABOUT A FEW WEEKS AGO
ACTUALLY MENTION THIS ON A
COUPLE OF SHOWS.
WE WERE GOING THROUGH THOSE
REPORTS AND THEN BEGINNING TO
MATCH THEM UP TO THE MOLAR
INDICTMENTS.
THE MOLAR RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
PROSECUTION.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
FOUND, AND LEE SMITH HAS DONE
SOME GREAT REPORTING ON THIS, IS
THAT -- REMEMBER THE WHOLE STORY
THAT TOP IT UP A LIST NEEDED TO
BE TREATED BADLY AND SENTENCED
TO SOME TIME BECAUSE HE RELEASED
FROM BEING ABLE TO FIND
JOSEPH?
AND ENDS UP THAT’S NOT TRUE.
THOUGH 302 IS ACTUALLY SAY THAT
HE WAS TRYING TO HELP THE FBI
AND SAID IT WAS GOING TO BE IN
THE UNITED STATES.
AND SO IF THE LAWYERS THAT WROTE
THAT TO THE COURT, THE
RECOMMENDATION TO THE COURT,
THEY NEED TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
SO WE ARE SCRUBBING THROUGH ALL
OF THESE 302’S, AND WE WILL BE
MAKING SOME TYPE OF CRIMINAL
REFERRAL, PERHAPS
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR IS AN
APPOINTED.
WE WILL SEE EXACTLY WHAT THAT
U.S. ATTORNEY IS LOOKING AT.
BUT IT’S NOT OKAY TO DIE LIE TO
FEDERAL JUDGE.
>> Laura: AS BRIAN SAID, AS
YOU SAID SO MANY TIMES, WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO TRUST OUR INTEL.
IT SHOULD NOT BE POLITICAL.
THE FBI HAS TO BE FAIR ACROSS
THE BOARD WITHOUT REGARD TO
PARTY POLITICS.
THAT’S ALL THE PRESIDENT IS
ASKING FOR.
HE’S NOT ASKING FOR SPECIAL